[Musique]
quand j'étais petit j'avais un rêve je
voulais être danseuse comme beaucoup de
petites filles mais vraiment pour moi la
danse elle était essentiel vital
nécessaire
je passais mon temps à danser je me
souviens même que dans notre appartement
pour passer d'une pièce à l'autre
virevoltaient ce qui faisait d'ailleurs
beaucoup rire ma grand mère je me levais
danse
je mangeais danse je dormais danse la
danse était tout mais alors tant que ça
reste une petite passion comme ça à côté
ça posait pas trop de problèmes mais
quand on classe de troisième à la
période sacro-sainte de l'orientation
des classes
la conseillère d'orientation m'a posé la
question et toi je vais faire quoi plus
tard moi j'ai dit ben je veux danser
je vais être danseuse dans mon entourage
plus ou moins proches et pour un tas de
raisons tout à fait en temps d'ablon
n'était pas très d'accord ni très
partant à l'idée de cette lubie
on me disait ah danse un métier un toit
gehl si brillant à l'école non toi toi
tu es une intello et surtout cette
phrase que j'ai vécue comme assassines
et franchement t'as pas le corps est
physique d'une danseuse 1 avec ta
cambrure toi tu as la poitrine à paris
les fesses à orléans donc le problème
c'est le corps le problème c'est mon
corps alors autant vous dire qu'à
l'adolescence en termes d' estime de soi
de confiance en soi suis au top au l'ex
younès de complexe poussé par tout ces
injonctions
je ferme la porte d'un rêve et je me
conforme
je construis mon identité sur cette idée
sur cette croyance que je ne peux pas
être danseuse parce que je n'ai pas le
corps et que montent
fort à moi c'est l'intellect et c'est
souvent ce qui se passe avec les enfants
suivis par exemple alexandre mais toi de
toute façon tu enchaînes colère sur
colère qui était un gamin colérique 1
c'est pas possible ça ou à sidonie série
à l'amp
qu'est ce qui était drôle plus tard tu
seras comique ou encore à karim web
avons vraiment tête en l'air quoi c'est
un gamin tête-en-l'air quoi final
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous coller une
étiquette à l'enfant et l'enfant bien
souvent par peur de ne plus être aimé
bien ils se conforment
il devient en émotions en comportement
précisément cette étiquette
alors en ce qui me concerne
vous allez voir je pousse le truc à fond
je passe un bac s scientifique celui
avec lequel ma conseillère d'orientation
me dit où on peut tout faire
je fais les classes préparatoires aux
grandes écoles hypokhâgne khâgne et puis
je quitte ma lorraine natale direction
paris la capitale non pas pour être
danseuse un non non je fais un doctorat
de littérature sur la littérature à
tence alors c'est pas nécessairement des
années de souffrance mais je sens bien
qu'au fond mais quelque chose qui cloche
suis pas tout à fait à ma place
puis vient le jeune âge adulte
les découvertes les voyages les
rencontres et on sait à quel point
certaines rencontres peuvent être
déterminantes dans notre parcours
j'ai la chance de partir à l'autre bout
du monde en asie du sud-est aux
philippines et aux philippines
je rencontre artix il est professeur de
danse chorégraphe et il mine ici à la
danse traditionnelle national de tiny
kling alors le tiny kling c'est une
danse qui porte le nom d'un petit oiseau
le ti kling et la légende raconte que ce
petit oiseau doit éviter les pièges
qu'on lui tend parmi les tiges de riz au
niveau de la danse deux percussionnistes
et tiennent des tige en bambou se font
face l'étape sur le sol ou l'une contre
l'autre
pendant que des danseurs de généralement
évolue parmi les tiges de bambou
en essayant de pas se faire croquer des
pieds une danse en somme où il faut
éviter les obstacles intéressant à la
fin de la danse art typo ses mains sur
mes épaules me regarde droit dans les
yeux et me dit pierre you will go dancer
cas une excellente danseuse
alors là c'est l'électrochoc
je suis complètement perdue d'un côté on
me dit que je ne peux pas être une
danseuse parce que j'en ai pas le corps
et de l'autre que je suis une très bonne
danseuse qui croire qu'est-ce que j'ai
expérimenté au juste avec archie ça
voudrait dire qu'on n'est pas seulement
ce que les autres disent de nous on
pourrait changer de perspective dans ce
cas qui décide alors et si c'était moi
est-ce qu'on pourrait aller au delà des
croyances limitantes que l'on a sur nous
mêmes et si oui comment
et cette question elle tourne en boucle
dans ma tête et plus elle tourne
plus j'y réfléchis plus je vois qu'elle
est partagée par d'autres ce jeune homme
qui voulait être avocat mais à qui on a
dit qu'il était dyslexique
cette jeune femme qui voulait être
médecin mais à qui on a dit qu'elle
était nulle en maths
cette attachée de presse qui voit son
rêve avorté parce qu'elle est trop
timide
ce jeune homme qui passe ses journées
dans un travail qu'ils détestent parce
que sa croyance à lui c'est un travail
c'est uniquement fait pour gagner de
l'argent
alors je mène l'enquêté
je me plonge corps et âme dans les
outils du changement
les outils psycho corporelle notamment
alors ce trajet c'est le mien peut-être
que si nous étions partis dans le même
pays nous ne serions pas passer par les
mêmes villes
c'est juste une proposition première
escale en pays sophrologie je découvre
la respiration le rythme de l'inspirent
de l'ex pire souffle
qui tout le temps là de notre naissance
jusqu'à notre mort et qui fait que tout
bouge tout le temps à l'intérieur
la sophrologie m'apprend également la
détente le relâchement musculaire à
apaiser les tensions physiques mais
aussi psychique et je découvre la
visualisation cette capacité formidable
que nous avons tous imaginé des contenus
mais pas seulement les imaginer les
ressentir par exemple a tout de suite on
pourrait imaginer une plage la voir
entendre le remous des vagues sentir le
vent qui caresse délicatement notre
visage le sable chaud sous la peau et
peut-être prendre le temps de prendre le
temps d'une inspiration pour prendre
tous ces contenus agréable et elle
expire pour les diffuser dans notre
corps la sophrologie m'apprend avoir un
nouveau regard sur l'existence et à
accueillir mes sensations comme elles
sont sans les juger je découvre la
méditation de pleine conscience là
mindfulness la méditation de pleine
présence grâce à elle j'apprends à être
dans l'expérience du moment présent ici
et maintenant j'apprends aussi que je
pense tout le temps et que je peux
absolument pas arrêter de penser
soixante mille pensées par jour en
moyenne
par contre je peux faire un petit pas de
côté mais ses passes et ses pensées et
ne pas les suivre
ne pas les charges et j'apprends à faire
un pas de côté par rapport à mai
conditionnement et par rapport à mes
jugements qui sont souvent très durs sur
moi même grâce à la méditation jeu
devient plus autonome plus libres se
découvre également la psychologie
positive qui m'apprend à travailler dans
le plein dans ce qui est déjà là plutôt
que d'aller chercher quelque chose que
je n'ai pas encore la psychologie
positive m'apprend à prendre conscience
de mes forces
de mes compétences
et tout ça et bien ça me bouge ça me
change et plus ça me change plus ça me
rend heureuse et plus ça me change ça me
rend heureuse
ça change aussi les autres autour de moi
comme une joyeuse contagion parce que
nous sommes tous interdépendants
si j'étais arrivé tout à l'heure d'un
pas lourd le visage visiblement très
agacé
peut-être que notre relation ne serait
pas la même terre dépendant je pratique
sans relâche ces outils je les incorpore
et j'en fais même mon métier je deviens
une experte je me forme à la sophrologie
à la méditation de pleine conscience et
j'en fais mon métier
et s'il ya une un endroit où j'ai envie
ou je trouve pertinent de bouger les
lignes
c'est l'éducation et il se trouve qu'en
2015 dans ma ville on me propose
d'intervenir
on cherche une personne qui a la double
compétence en sophrologie et en
méditation de pleine présence est oui
petite précision qui a son importance
j'habite à saint denis en seine saint
denis un territoire qui n'est pas
spécialement réputé pour sa pratique
active de la plaine présence et de la
détente
la proposition c'est d'intervenir en
milieu scolaire dans un collège
on a remarqué chez les élèves un manque
d'attention un manque de concentration
une grande impulsivité qui gêne les
apprentissages classique et occasionne
des situations de grand stress de grande
violence aussi le projet s'est également
d'évaluer par une recherche scientifique
l'impact de ces deux techniques la
sophrologie la méditation en fonction de
l'âge des élèves alors je peux vous dire
que là la petite intello le côté
recherche scientifique
elle est contente mon envie à moi c'est
de travailler avec tous les éléments du
système
les élèves les enseignants et les
parents
mais au départ il faut bien avouer que
les adultes sont un petit peu frileux à
l'idée de ces pratiques qui jouissent
encore d'une mauvaise réputation en 2015
on pense que la sophrologie est un peu
trop sectaire et on se demande bien ce
que la méditation va faire à l'école
qu'à cela ne tienne je commence avec les
élèves
nous organisons des ateliers sur la
pause méridienne
alors autant vous dire que quand
j'arrive
ils ne sont pas assis en posture du
lotus les yeux fermés
allez
[Applaudissements]
comment ça se passe par une rencontre je
négociais que l'établissement de
rencontrer les élèves qui sont donc
obligés de venir et dans cette rencontre
je présente les techniques je me
présente et nous pratiquons les élèves à
l'issue de cette présentation peuvent ou
non s'inscrire en pleine conscience aux
ateliers dans ces ateliers nous
apprenons des exercices des techniques
de respiration à sentir notre corps et
nous pratiquons bardon d'autres
compétences comme l'empathie la
gratitude car oui tout comme la
confiance en soi estime de soi
l'empathie et la gratitude ça s'apprend
par exemple nous terminons chaque
atelier nous sommes installés en cercle
par un partage d'un petit moment
agréable de la journée
je vous invite à faire fait en famille
si vous avez des enfants ou entre
adultes peut-être au moment du dîner par
exemple de partager chacun un petit
moment agréable de votre journée à
l'issue de la première année les élèves
expérimente des changements et les
adultes eux observent ces changements
moins de bagarres - le conseil de
discipline meilleure attention et un
meilleur accueil des émotions et ça ça
donne envie aux adultes de s'y mettre
donc la deuxième année nous proposons un
atelier de pratique pour les enseignants
et aussi des découvertes pour les
parents lors de portes ouvertes de café
des parents et on va même plus loin on
propose une formation aux enseignants
pour faire descendre ses techniques dans
les classes en complément d
apprentissage classique
c'est donc tout le système qui se
retrouvent impact et c'est pas toujours
simple il faut beaucoup de patience
beaucoup de perspicacité et il ya des
moments je me sens plutôt comme une
dompteuse de lyon voyez je me souviens
d'ailleurs d'une place de 4e nous en
étions à la sixième séance sur les huit
autant vous dire à la fin du programme
et le jour
de l'atelier arrivée la situation est
totalement incontrôlable ça crie ça
s'insulte ça saute partout et là je
prends conscience que mes outils et bien
ils ont leurs limites
je suis vraiment complètement des
mulliez qu'est ce que je fais
j'accueille déjà le fait que je ne peux
pas gérer cette situation
je ne sais pas comment faire et je
m'installe je pratique au bout de 45
minutes de pratique et 45 minutes les
plus longues de toute ma vie
un élève s'asseoir puis un autre puis un
autre puis un autre et à la fin nous
sommes tous en présence pendant 10
secondes victoire ce jour là j'apprends
quelque chose d'essentiel et que bien
sûr sophrologie méditation et toute
autre technique mais ce qui compte c'est
avant tout la façon dont nous les
incarnent
notre présence notre déontologie notre
authenticité notre exemplarité aussi
actuellement ce projet continue
d'évoluer
nous formons des élèves ambassadeurs
dans chaque classe ainsi que des
enseignants pour que ses façons d'être
ces techniques se transmettent dans les
générations à venir et ça fait tâche
d'huile sur le département puisque les
écoles élémentaires des lycées pratique
également la sophrologie la méditation
en seine-saint-denis alors que nous
apprennent cette petite fille qui
voulait trop danseuse cette expérience
de méditation de sophrologie en
seine-saint-denis c'est que même dans
l'espace le plus contre un il y a
toujours des choses qui dépendent de
nous et c'est là précisément là que se
situe notre marge de liberté
il s'agit pas de grands changements de
commencer par soi pour petit à petit
changer autour de soi
apa un peu comme des colibris petit à
petit moi c'est ce que j'appelle danser
sa vie est vraiment je vous souhaite du
fond du coeur
pourquoi pas à vous aussi de danser
votre vie et c'est maintenant je vous
remercie infiniment de votre écoute et
du fond du coeur
[Applaudissements]